les plus spectaculaires de l'histoire
des échecs il y a plus d'un siècles dans
cette position il a les noirs et son
adversaire vient d'attaquer sa dame sa
tendance certainement une fuite paisible
quand un coup de tonnerre vient faire
trembler l'échiquier le génie américain
offre sa dame en pâture au pion adverse
provoquant l'abandon immédiat alors
pourquoi ce coup de folie est en réalité
un coup de génie si le pion h capture la
dame le cavalier vient délivrer sur le
champ un matériaux F accepte ce cadeau
empoisonné cavalier donne de nouveau
échecs le roi est objet de fuir dans le
coin et la tour vient délivrer un mat du
couloir troisième possibilité capturer
la dame avec sa propre dame de nouveau
les Noirs font échec le roi est obligé
d'aller dans le coin le cavalier
récupère la dame sur échec du pion RH et
cloué le Pione F ne peut reprendre sous
peine de maths du couloir une nouvelle
fois le roi doit donc revenir sur ses
pas le cavalier refait l'échec le roi
bouge de nouveau et la tour peut
simplement s'enfuir et si on ne mate pas
avec les noirs on termine avec une pièce
de plus ce qui est à ce niveau équivaut
évidemment à une victoire